I thought we might close.
I have a question for you about your,
your derivation of these moral virtues specifically from the enlightenment and
I'm curious about that because,
well,
first of all you could make a case that it wasn't so much the enlightenment as
it was the specifically the rise of empirical science and then you could of
course have a discussion about how those two things are related.
But I'm also curious,
I've been reading Ian McGilchrist book,
the master and his emissary and Miguel.
Chris makes a pretty strong case.
I would say that yet the rationalistic enlightenment values are in some sense a
consequence of the articulation of an underlying set of principals that are more
metaphoric in nature,
more narrative in nature.
The case,
I also made it my book maps of meeting and to some degree in 12 rules for life
that the enlightenment project,
and it's rationalities nested inside a deeper web of metaphor and ritual and
damage that would be associated with longer scale cognitive processes,
some of which are expressed in religious thinking,
but some of which are grounded in not so much rationality as in motivation and
emotion.
And I mean the way your book is structured,
and I think the way enlightenment thinkers think is that there was a miracle of
sorts that occurred sometime in the last three to 500 years and people woke up
and became rational.
And then the question is to what degree was the ground for that awakening
prepared by events that weren't the awakening itself but that were associated
with other processes?
And I'm just curious as to what your thoughts are on that.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
there's nothing new under the sun and a,
I have good intellectual historian can find the antecedents of any intellectual
movement didn't in various precursors.
Um,
you know,
it's hard to,
I,
I don't think there's a,
a lot in the enlightenment that can specifically be attributed to,
um,
to uh,
uh,
religion,
particularly Christianity just based on the fact that it was already around for
a thousand years and nothing much happened.
So it couldn't be religion itself or Christianity itself.
Although there are as,
as you say,
there are strands that were carried over in particular.
And this is a,
I didn't cite that,
that I got from my other half,
Rebecca Goldstein,
my wife,
uh,
who,
you've appeared on stage.
One of it,
one thing that the Greeks didn't have that,
uh,
the Christianity did,
was the idea of compassion for the week and,
and universal human flourishing.
Uh,
you don't really have that for all of the brilliance of,
uh,
of ancient Greece.
That wasn't a big feat.
But the enlightenment of course,
did not spring out of,
out of nowhere.
If I were to identify the antecedents,
what and why,
what happened prior to the 18th century that allowed it to kind of pull down as
opposed to a couple of hundred years earlier,
a couple of hundred years later,
one of them was the scientific revolution conventionally located in the,
in the 17th century,
which not only provided a paradigm for understanding,
namely,
uh,
testing propositions against the empirical world,
seeking deeper,
naturalistic explanations for phenomena.
And which of course overturned a millennia.
Old Dogmas reminding people that bear their own common sense,
their own societies,
convictions.
Uh,
we're fallible.
So that was,
uh,
an essential precursor.
Another one was the discovery of the,
uh,
of the new world.
That there were entire civilizations,
entire world,
literally worlds in their sense that that had been a unknown in that the
knowledge base that they have been part of a Western civilization for Millennia
was radically incomplete.
And technologically,
I suspect that the,
the greater,
uh,
exchange of ideas and people,
was a contributor there prior to be just prior to be lightened in the second
half of the 18th century.
There's a massive growth in the efficiency of,
uh,
printing printing presses itself.
But it was the democratization of books and pamphlets,
the rise literacy,
uh,
and the movement of people.
It became easier for,
uh,
for heretics and radicals to jump ship and move to where things were cooler if
things got too uncomfortable where they were.
And it's amazing how many of the enlightenment thinkers were persecuted for
their beliefs.
They were threatened with imprisonment or death.
Many of them ended up in,
in Holland or Paris or London or jumped around to wherever they had made the
greatest freedom,
but also just the sheer,
uh,
I'll kind of precursor of the,
the web today.
The fact that pamphlet can be introduced and within a few months it would be
translated into,
uh,
a dozen European languages and,
and smuggled in.
So the exchange of,
of ideas,
uh,
I think,
help to accelerate the,
uh,
the enlightenment.
Although since it only happened once in human history,
we can never really know for sure why it happened when it did,
but at those are three.
Good,
good.
Yes.
Well,
I mean,
we're in an interesting time now where we can sit and make a video like this and
publish it almost instantaneously and share it with half a million people.
I mean that that ability to share ideas rapidly is developing a pace and God
only knows what the consequence of that is.
We're,
we're in a situation now,
which was only occurred to me about last year,
where the spoken word for the first time in human history has the same reach and
longevity as the written word.
And it's easier for people to listen.
You know,
audio books are becoming very popular.
Lots and lots of people listen to podcasts,
know I have working class people come to my talks all the time and say,
look,
I'm sitting in my forklift for three hours a day and I'm doing nothing but
listening to podcasts,
you know?
So that's,
that's a really remarkable thing.
So I think,
I think I'm going to let you go.
You've been very generous with your time.
I appreciate the conversation very much.
I'm going to close by
showing your book again and Steven Pinker's new book enlightenment now,
which is tearing up the bestseller charts and which is a guide to proper end
intelligent optimism in the 21st century.
And maybe I'd ask you just in closing,
what do you think there are things that individuals,
what do you think individuals should be particularly optimistic about right now?
And what do you think individuals could do to spread the message that things are
getting better and that we can solve our problems?
Yeah.
Um,
the fact that there are new efforts to try transcend political divisions and
find out what works to depoliticize and rationalize,
uh,
problems like poverty,
like climate change,
uh,
like,
like war and peace like crime.
Um,
those are very much worth supporting that there are organizations like at a
political,
there are NGOs that tried to monitor the state of the world.
There's effective altruism that just the general application of rationality to
solve our problems that is responsible for the progress that we've enjoyed in
the past.
And if there's going to be progress ahead of us will be responsible for what
will enjoy in the future.
All right,
well,
I'm,
um,
would like to close to by mentioning to everyone who's listening that you know,
things aren't getting better.
They're getting better because people are facing problems and actually trying to
solve them.
They're doing micro analysis of the problems,
breaking them down into their constituent elements,
being humble enough to use incremental solutions to solve them.
And to address them at,
at at a high level of resolution instead of a low level of,
or a low resolution level of ideological debate.
And it's really working.
And I would,
um,
what would we say encourage people to pick up Dr Pinker's book because the world
is getting better and we should know it and we should be happy about it.
And we should continue to foster that development in every way that we can.
And I think this is an excellent,
this book is an excellent contribution to that effort as well as your other
books like are,
are better rangers,
better,
better angels of our nature.
So thank you very much for spending the time with me today and for talking with
me and it was a pleasure to meet you.
Thanks so much.
Thanks for having a Jordan.
Who's the pleasure was mine.